hi so this video is just a bit of a
public service announcement to let you
guys know that I'll be going to
Switzerland to attend a symposium at the
University of st. Gallen I'll be part of
a forum of discussion on the topic of
disruptive ideas the attendees will be
comprised of what are dubs leaders of
tomorrow and also established people in
the industry the symposium is in its
47th er and previous attendees have
included Jack Ma CEO of Alibaba and
Christine Lagarde head of the
International Monetary Fund or IMF I'm
really hoping to meet some interesting
people and our report back on my
experiences after Switzerland I'll be
traveling to Budapest in Hungary and
Croatia for a few days each so if any of
you around the area are be keen to meet
some of you guys now originally I had
some great videos lined up when I was
away topics like how big is YouTube and
who controls all of our money the second
video was a look at central banking and
the real truth about how our world works
it's a topic that I've been looking into
for the past four years and right now I
think the time is right for this
knowledge to be shared unfortunately I
ran out of time to complete these videos
before my leaving date and my laptop
screen is currently smashed so I can't
work while I'm away but I aim to get
those videos completed by the end of May
when I return back to Perth anyway
thanks for watching and I'll catch you
guys again soon for the next video
Cheers have a good one